they're just bloodthirsty when it comes
to Donald Trump they don't care what the
consequences are of locking them up for
something that's completely absurd it's
it's it's it's obviously political
persecution right obviously it's
obviously political persecution
persecution but I don't think they care
at all and I don't even think that they
care like I don't think they're thinking
far enough ahead to even see this being
uh a major help to Donald Trump in his
campaign he's already raising money
using this to raise money right now this
is going to be the biggest thing for his
campaign if you think that the energy
behind Donald Trump's campaign in 2016
was big this is this is what we're
seeing right now in the US that we're
living in today and what we're seeing
right now with this political
persecution this is 10 times worse than
when he was elected